طبعا عايزين نقدرنا الموضوع الفني للملف
لا شك ان في البدايات كان يعني كان الناس
ينظرون الى ملف قطر ان فيه صعوبات كثيره
بس كعدت ما استطعنا من ان نحول الصعوبات
الى ايجابيات
في البدايه يمكن لحد شهر 2 من 2010
[موسيقى]
جاي يتقدم الملف مجرد لتقديم الملف بس مثل
اهداف
[موسيقى]
اكيد جميع العيون علينا ولهذا تم
الاستعداد لهذه البطوله من اكثر من عشر
سنوات
[موسيقى]
لا شك بالنسبه لنا طبعا وهذا تعنينا كمان
ضمين انا في وجهه نظري نجاح اي بطوله احد
العناصر الاساسيه والرئيسيه هم المتطوعين
لان هم الاشخاص اللي راح يكون على تواصل
بشكل كبير مع الجمهور
كما ان احد اكثر الاسئله التي دمر يتم
سؤالي عنها في بلده هو هل يفرض علي لبس
الحجاب وبالطبع الجواب لا والكثير من مثل
هذا النمط من الاسئله مثل السؤال عن مصطلح
الشريعه التي لا يعرفها الناس حقا ولا
يفهمونها ولدي فقط افتراضات بشانها لذا
اعتقد ان مجرد القدره على المجيء
[موسيقى]
الى هنا
طريقه عمل يمكن كان جديد على عالم كره
القدم الدوليه اوقات الاجتماعيه
تغيير الفكره النبطيه اللي موجوده
اللي دائما سهل بالنسبه للعالم الخارجي
انه يتهم اي شخص من الوطن العربي عربي
فتكون البشر
[موسيقى]